là le plaisir de recevoir aujourd'hui
elodie mélodie mais l areq merci elodie
vous êtes comportementaliste de
profession vous avez soigneusement
décrypter les 13 minutes du discours d'
emmanuel macron confie j'ai l'eau dit
mme pelosi on y va de vous répondre
alors ce que je trouve intéressant alors
vous dites finalement la sincérité c'est
pas une question de fond quand on entend
et quand on regarde un petit peu les
sondages et la façon dont justement
certains français ont des attentes
justement par rapport à cette classe
politique on se rend compte qu
effectivement ya un amalgame ses terres
qu'aujourd'hui ce qui est quand même
attendu la part d'un homme politique
c'est de pouvoir incarner ce qu'il
raconte incarner son discours et ça ça
passe par des systèmes de sincérité et
alors que ça nous plaise donc ça nous
plaise pas et en tous les cas moi je ne
suis pas là pour juger mais on va
effectivement vers un glissement qui est
qu'aujourd'hui un homme politique qui ne
paraît pas authentique ce qui ne paraît
pas sincère n'est plus crédible et c'est
aussi sans doute ce qui fait du mal on
sait que la classe politique des plus
crédibles
alors bientôt alors il faut dire que
c'est pas rien donc c'est quand même
important de savoir est-ce qu'il est
sincère ou pas et servait qu'à à quel
moment et sur quel sujet il l'est
davantage c'est pour ça que je posais la
question je suis pas complètement con
tout merci alors donc que ça veut dire
pour vous sincère c'est à dire qu'ils
croient en ce qu'ils disent oui oui bah
non acars qui dit non non non il n'y a
pas que ça c'est ce qu'ils ont mais vous
sous marine le pen sports et qu'elle est
censée non mais non c'est ce qui laisse
à faire quand il comprend la la la la
voilà à clé les les français souffrent
ce dans une empathie pratique oui c'est
plus à l apprenant un détecteur de
mensonges à chaque club a son style audi
n'en est qu'un garçon bien qu'on ait
retrouvé
alors oui tout ça alors là sont là ce
qui est intéressant c'est qu'on est au
tout début de sa prise de parole alors
on se doute que effectivement ça va être
assez statique parce que lui dans ses
prises de parole habituels ça c'est pas
danse avec les stars
voilà il ne bouge pas beaucoup la sq est
très intéressant c'est que quand vous
regardez alors il ya un homme qui est
plus grand que l'autre notamment voyez
alors à la bouche pour vous voici un
petit peu plus petits pourquoi on fait
alors il ya un chercheur rodgers perica
une prix nobel en 81 est ce qu'il a
montré que nos hémisphères cérébraux
était latéralisé effectivement il ya
fort à penser que en ce qui concerne le
non verbal c'est la même chose c'est ce
qui se passe à la gauche du corps et ce
qui se passe à la droite du corps n'a
pas tout à fait la même signification
et ça et ça donc ça retombe et 15 h ça
montre alors on a plutôt tendance à dire
que ce qui se passe parce qu'on pense
tout ce qu'on est très symétriques mais
en fait on ne l'ait pas vu et on a
plutôt tendance à décoder en tous les
cas c'est le cas en synergologie que
tout ce qui se passe sur la gauche du
corps est plutôt lié au relationnel au
personnel et ce qui se passe à la droite
du corps c'est plutôt la dimension alors
le repas il a choisi mentionnant qu'il
ya une erreur de prendre seulement
légèrement trop avec ça je sais ça non
mais ça non mais le regard à l'ère des
cadets oui je vous dire je peux pas
produire toutes les émissions mais ça
c'est sûr corbières se produit et
psychologie c'est des choses
autant je t'assure que le regard à l'air
décalé quand tu regardes alors alors
qu'est ce que ça veut dire qu'on tourne
à une multi ça fait là en gros c'est un
item de l'impact émotionnel d'accord
stress émotionnel et là on est plutôt
sur une émotion négative qui est qui et
avec donc il était stressé avant ça
l'auteur d' inventions pour 8 août a
fait mais c'est pas nouveau sticker
rationnelle c'est qu'il est mentionné
lmnp il est réellement impactée
mais c'est quasiment tout autre chose
sinon regarder les traits du visage
on voit déjà qu'au niveau du regard
s'est jamais la même chose oui mais ce
qui est intéressant c'est que ça bouge
ses terres adverses je n'aurais pu avoir
son oeil droit corps était plus petit et
là en fait c'est la seule aile gauche
port et l'oeil gauche ça veut dire que
c'est le l'émotion les yeux de son fils
sincère ou pas vous voyez froid j'ai un
regard bah oui bah là c'est le social
vous avez l'oeil droit c'est le social
or c'est donc à droite sa droite adultes
et sa gauche alors autre chose et
l'odeur allez-y donc la sq est très
intéressant et ça ça a été beaucoup noté
1 0 dans les réseaux sociaux le fait qu'
il y ait les mains qu'ils soient bien
posé à plat on valide et là on tombe un
petit peu dans les travers de la
personne qui est hyper coach et avec
beaucoup de communiquant autour qui sans
doute lui ont dit il faut pas bouger il
faut rester statique sauf que en termes
de production et des faits de sens en
termes de réception
et bien ça donne une dimension très
automates très de l'ordre de la
récitation et ça se voit aussi puisque
vous l'avez dit un regard qui est
décalée on lit le prompteur et à quoi on
voit aussi la récitation
c'est comme les enfants quand ils
récitent un poème devant toute la classe
il ne quitte plus des yeux et ça le
clignement de paupière effectivement
c'est un item qui montre qu'il est hyper
concentré hyper en classe et ça c'est
petit c'est plutôt bon signe ou pas ça
montre que il est beaucoup dans la
répétition dans la récitation et quand
on est sur une épreuve qui est une
épreuve de mea culpa et une épreuve de
reconnaître ses torts et de faire des
excuses
du coup ça crée un décalage c'est à dire
de dire de manière très robotique je
m'excuse et d'ailleurs il l'a pas dit en
ces termes parce que il l'a toujours
utilisé des tournures de phrases qui
sont beaucoup plus d incarner avec des
îles des il vous a semblé que parfois
quand j'étais donc il
il met beaucoup à distance mais du coup
ça crée l'impression qu'il ya quelque
chose qui se fait pas c'est d'accès des
excuses mais en demi teinte alors autre
chose on a quoi d'autre là c'est quoi la
wii alors c'est exactement ce que je
vous disais c'est ça c'était pour que
vous voyez l'absence de kliment de la
corse était donc là ça c'était de ça on
l'a fait à ses yeux sont garantis
quelque chose alors là vous voyez
justement par rapport à la séquence où
il était beaucoup plus rigide où il
était droit là qu'est ce que vous voyez
au niveau de la tête ça bouge un petit
peu plus il ya beaucoup plus de mal à
votre santé d'ailleurs vous voyez il
pense peut-être vers l'avant bush des
avantages très contrastée par rapport à
cette posture est bbb
dans l'ordre et dans ce contexte assez
mais reviennent macro qui est arrivé sur
le plateau j'ai eu peur on en près de 40
ans il a aidé vision nous mieux
durant cette période les plus riches
partent et et notre pays s'affaiblit si
peur conformément aux engagements pris
devant vous cet impôt a été supprimée
pour ceux qui investissent dans notre
économie et donc aide à créer des
emplois et il a été maintenu au
contraire pour ceux qui ont une fortune
immobilière alors là il a l'air très
calme la wii mais ce qui est très
intéressant c'est de voir toute la
séquence avec le son qui est fermé et de
se rendre compte à quel moment le corps
est mobile et malheurs plus incarner des
50 sociétés insurgés et là typiquement
il est sur une séquence où il est
beaucoup plus mobile c'est à dire qu'il
est beaucoup plus incarné il ya plus
d'eau qu'anticipé
et ça tombe sur la sécu mais pendant des
mois et c'est tout à fait intéressant
c'est que il dit
le fait de dire que le soulier sf les
plus riches partait tout en études
démontrent que c'est faux on avait 4 ans
en mai sera un autre débat animé trois
mais c'est ça qui est important de
débattre alors est ce qu'il a fait sans
il est sincère lorsqu'il y en a chez
nous alors que le moment où il est le
plus animé et finalement le plus humain
le plus incarner c'est quand il évoque
l' isf ou visiblement fatigué non je
vais regarder la séquence le soutien
d'autres choses bailly des odeurs
idéologues
ouais c'est ça elle elle donne juste ce
qu'elle dit voilà ce que ce que j'ai je
voudrais fait bien que cet art fait j'ai
un moment donné où il ya certes y fait
qu'il est tout à fait sûr de son coup
entre guillemets et où il a une parole
qui est une parole beaucoup plus vivante
c'est effectivement ces cantines alors
est ce que pour vous il est déjà réservé
aux parisiens savent que de la pauvreté
ça voulait dire
mais combien ils placent ils parlent les
jaunes à la place à l'ex ecover c'est
comme si vous demandiez à jacques chirac
place un jour j'avais grand plaisir
qu'ils apprennent tout ça tombe bien le
gilet bleu mons en train de grignoter
dans la famille sur ces huitièmes il dit
je vous le dis oui alors il a été
sincère ou pas la plupart du temps il a
été en contrôle et sans plaisir que
c'est normal parce que c'est un exercice
effectivement qui peut être stressant et
on imagine bien que il a été coach et
lui a dit que voilà il fallait pas trop
bouger mais sur un exercice qui est
intéressant c'est ça c'est de voir la
tente qui était suscité autour de ce
discours là qu'était un discours de
est-ce qu'il va reconnaître ou pas
jusqu'où va-t-il aller bas il ya toute
une partie où les traits robotique et
c'est plutôt sur cette dimension on
l'attendait un petit peu plus chaleureux
et un peu plus dans le bas j'ai entendu
je vous jeu est d'ailleurs ses 85 ans ce
discours c'est que quand on regarde les
pronoms personnels qui sont le plus
utilisés il ya beaucoup de jeu il ya du
nous aussi donc une espèce de mythologie
de l'union et du nous que l'on retrouve
d'ailleurs une perte de nation c'est pas
anodin ce terme de nation c'est un terme
qui a commencé a été utilisé dans
l'histoire de france au moment de la
révolution française
bref parenthèse fermée mais ya pas de
vous d'autres n'y a pas de dialogue
finalement c'est normalement un jeu et
un vous est par ailleurs ils n'utilisent
jamais les termes gilet jaune et il ya
un postulant linguistique qui dit que
ceux qui ne se nomme pas n'existe pas
donc quelque part de ne pas dire gilet
jaune directement c'est aussi donner une
importance à la fin du jeu fait quand
même bien il y en a eu deux ou trois
c'est maintenant discret non consommée
c'est pas maintenant commente oui je
vous assure que je l'écouterai un joli
mais moi je ressens
je suis maladroit non attendez moi ma
posture elle est très simple elle
reprend d'ailleurs celle de fraude qui
dit il ya un plus d'un siècle je n'ai
pas inventé l'inconscient à une envie
irrépressible de s'exprimer et il le
fait à travers le langage et ce qui est
très intéressant et moi d'ailleurs
j'adore emmanuel macron pour ça parce
que c'est un champ d'expertisé
un corpus a analysé qui est
extraordinaire c'est comment il a une
difficulté quand même à sortir de
schèmes verticaux ses terres que la
façon dont il perçoit les gens c'est les
premiers corps délai dernier de cordée
enfin tout ça ce sont des expressions
que c'est pas moi qui les ai inventées
mais non mais pas du tout non mais
s'intéresse à vous avez bien qu dont il
dénomme les gerbes la personne monde
alors oui les personnes dont il parle
est fièrement voit bien dans son
discours il ya certes les premiers de
cordée il ya sans doute les smicards
l'on sent bien qu'il ya une zone qui
n'existe pas et qu'on ne perçoit pas
dans son discours il n'ya pas les thèmes
pour les nommer c'est la zone
intermédiaire massy et ça c'est une
analyse linguistique n'est pas
idéologique ce qui les concerne non pas
du tout mais vous a convaincu elodie
l'offre elle dit oui oui c'est très
pertinent
franchement merci merci